a lawsuit against Harvard the outcome
could affect the future of affirmative
action Harvard has been sued for
illegally discriminating against
asian-americans the legal action forced
the school to make its admissions data
public for the first time that did
reveal that Asian applicants must score
22 points higher on the SAT than whites
63 points higher than blacks
nevertheless Harvard denies it
discriminates against asian-americans or
any other group Harvard says race is
just one factor among many that is just
a lie Li Chang supports the students
suing the school Harvard didn't just use
race as one of many factors
it was the determinative factor Harvard
says many Americans of Asian descent
don't get in because they score lower in
personal attributes Harvard rated
asian-americans on personality right on
subjective factors like likability and
courage lower this is because
asian-americans are boring little
grade-grubbers they just focus on
getting good grades and good test scores
I can categorically say that's [ __ ]
if you only look at grades and test
scores it looks like a lot of
discrimination against Asians economist
Harry Holzer who went to Harvard defends
the school Asians are not interesting
they don't have interesting qualities
but the personal ratings reflect a wide
range of of characteristics now it's
possible it's possible that some of that
is anti Asian bias but you certainly
can't prove that oh I don't think
they're discriminating against Asians
but I assume they're discriminating for
blacks and Latinos because there's been
a history of discrimination I wouldn't
label it discrimination I would label it
as leveling the playing field I mean if
that discrimination no no it's it's it's
race-conscious assistance and when you
have a long history of discrimination
based on race you have to take race into
account hasn't Harvard like lots of
other schools been deceitful about what
they're doing they basically lied for
years I don't know if they're like they
were putting their own spin this case is
expected to get to the Supreme Court and
the new court may ban racial preferences
if that happens you'll see a large
increase
the white student population and you see
a precipitous decline and the black and
Latino student population about 50% 50%
decline in those of color Harvard would
be a less interesting placement if that
happens there are many many different
ways to achieve diversity without
discriminating against asian-americans
the reality is that race focused
affirmative action helps rich people
seventy percent of the students of every
ethnic group at Harvard come from the
top 20% of family a family income I
think it's okay
that some of the minorities admitted
under affirmative action come from
higher income families race in America
matters at any level of income the
groups that are harmed the most are
Ashley poor whites and poor Asians Chang
is passionate about ending racial
preferences because when he was in the
eighth grade he applied to San
Francisco's Lowell high school I was
just shocked when I found out I had to
score higher than kids of any other
ethnic group because I'd just taken
civics
I was just taught in civics and history
that in America everybody was supposed
to be equal under the law Lowell High
School excels in everything from music
to math Jane got into that high school
but the kids were negatively affected
were the kids of the dishwashers and the
seamstresses who lived in Chinatown were
very important Chang later went to
Harvard he became a lawyer and
successfully sued San Francisco over its
race-based preferences so we got rid of
the quotas in San Francisco you agents
we white people we're doing well in
America we don't need extra help but
some other groups do and there's a
history of nasty discrimination against
them
isn't it Harvard's job to try to make up
for some of that the right path out of
the history of discrimination against
individuals based on race is not more
discrimination based on race I have
three kids and I'll be damned if I'm
going to not fight very very hard to
make sure that they don't get treated a
second-class citizens no land in which
they were born